i know how much dedication you have i
mean the fact that you're 46 and still
doing what 26 year olds maybe can do is
insane
but i know that you have a lot of
dedication and that your whole day
is
around rehab the training
um
you know the body and stretching and all
the things so like where have i caught
you at this moment today
today well you know i usually take my
daughters to my wife take the kids to
school and i just went for a little
exercise post retirement from temple
florida and then uh spending some time
with you know people ask me what do you
do besides running or what's the other
hobby is spend time with family and
friends so i was just having a nice
coffee traditional eritrean ethiopian
coffee which is usually not a starbucks
30 minutes it's usually a couple hours
so
i'm at halfway mark and i said i got to
go to go talk to the don and danica
what has that transition been like for
you
the transition for retirement is great
to spend time with family and friends
but at the same time sometimes is with
so much into routines and goals and
um
tight schedule it's kind of like you
feel guilty
yeah to be like well i should be doing
this because when you're a runner
whether like you said earlier whether
you're doing therapy whether you're
doing massages whether you're doing
second run or crash training or
weightlifting and all that stuff your
mind is
taken away and you know whether you are
eating and what you gotta have to
prepare for or get ready for the next
day for the next week for the next month
or for the next race you're constantly
thinking but now it's like um you know
you were doing so many things now it's
kind of slowed down a little bit i mean
how much do you train now i guess i mean
his training now is just your well-being
as opposed to for a specific goal which
i'm actually curious first off how much
different is that like
just for the for the regular human right
that goes
how much training do you do for your
health and well-being versus how much
was for
marathon training
you know danica this is kind of crazy
but i used to train about 100 to 130
miles a week
so people often ask you you're a runner
you run every day and you're like well i
run 12 times a week uh so that puts it
in perspective but now
as a retirement for health you know
after i retire for about maybe like four
or five months i was still running like
10 miles a day for six seven days a week
so i'm like what am i doing this for
again and then you have to kind of scale
it down to whether you want to run five
miles or four miles and not feel guilty
about it because before it was like my
cooldown
after three mile warm up a hard workout
and then a cool down sometimes i do
three miles four miles maybe five miles
so i can take the afternoon off to let
the bar recover now i'm running that
much you know what i used to do in cool
down i'm doing it for my health so it's
kind of you know different because
it was very intense pretty intense to be
able to just be on the grind day in day
out and you know get ready for
competition get ready for uh you know
get into therapy or massage or always on
the go because that time crunch is
important to do that first run recover
and eat and then do re for the second
run so it's constantly thinking until
you put your head on the pillow you're
constantly thinking what can i do to
better myself and especially when
sponsors and people are counting on you
you don't want to disappoint them
because you know you drive the car but
you know there's a team behind the team
and i run the 26.2 miles but there's a
team behind the team so you don't want
to disappoint them you want to give them
110 and sometimes it goes really well
and other times it doesn't because
mishap has happened or mistakes happen
and but you should be grateful that you
know you put 110 percent so retirement
now for health is good because my mental
is difficult
physically is okay because i run four
five six miles i'm completely happy with
that what i was
five six days a week if i could do a
seven days body is help your body is
good with that but your mind is saying
your mind is like lazy
exactly you know sometimes you see
people you know for the first time in my
life you know people are doing kind of
more than i'm running they're like hey
i'm gonna take the day off and not feel
guilty and then like i had a friend in
san diego she's like i'm not gonna say
who but two of us ran and this guy did
not run you know usually it's the other
the other way around saying hey can i
get a pacer on the bike or can i get
somebody to give me fluid and things
like that you're working very hard but
now it's like okay i need to be on a
chill mode and so mentally that
perspective has been different but also
i have to teach it kind of really
re-learn how to calm down and not what
not because for my life for me as a
being an immigrant
you know education was important so when
i was at ucl until i get that ucla
degree i was
non-stop eight o'clock class for five
years just go go go go maybe i miss
three times or four times besides
traveling from classes so and now you're
gonna be a freshman athlete for 17 18
years that was intense to be able to
just be on the grind they end up because
we don't have seasons and it's not like
four months and then you take off
distance runners you're constantly in
the year round so you kind of feel like
a little bit of burnout so you got to
slow down and reteach yourself it's okay
to breathe it's okay to not be your mind
wander around the next and the next
thing yeah do you remember
where or what happened when you kind of
hit that spot because i think a lot of
people can relate to the fact that
there's change that doing something
differently for a lot of people might be
training more um you know
but it's just it's still a similar
challenge emotionally and mentally and
so what happened it was there like a
breaking point or a moment that you
remember going okay something needs to
change and was there a breakdown
or was it possibly some kind of slow
progression
slow progression and i got to credit my
wife erdanos and she just says you know
sometimes you just gotta breathe you
know you you're you have
you worked hard for the rest of your
life now you need to kind of chill but
then another person cassandra carr she's
part of the owner of the san antonio
spurs i remember she says retirement is
different
you just do something that you used to
enjoy it doesn't mean you stop doing
everything you know it just means you
got to find something passion that you
are you are excited about so i remember
i was in san antonio and having a hobby
my brother and manager he was there and
we were having at her house just kind of
relaxing having a tea and she says man
retirement is just doing something
different that you love and you don't
have to stop just but now you can you
can go on your on your schedule what you
want to do versus completely stop and if
you just try to completely stop it's not
it's not great for anybody you know it's
not good for for you mentally and
physically but if you do a little bit of
something and a little bit of another
thing eventually passion will take over
yeah i mean that makes sense it's like
anything and there's like uh even some
level of like uh an addiction almost to
it where you know you have to you don't
just i mean cold turkey's a little
dramatic and so you know having kind of
that fade in that new transition and
creating new habits is you know part of
the process of weaning off and sort of
shifting
uh shifting your daily activity so what
were some things that you did that you
always wanted to do maybe it was food
maybe it was travel maybe it was
um i don't know drinking alcohol because
all i know is training for this marathon
i'm like you know in the last like
because the marathon's a couple weeks
away so um
i'm like i mean i have one glass of wine
now and i feel like i feel terrible from
it i feel like my recovery is horrible
my sleep is garbage like you know there
are things that you know really change
when you have that level of intensity of
doing something so i'm curious what
those things were that you thought about
maybe while you were training in in that
intensity that you thought man if i had
time or man if i didn't have to do this
in the morning i would do it
you know it's uh for me getting up early
in the morning you know whether it was
before flight or training schedule you
got to get that running before going the
next flight because it might be to
europe it might be time zone changes and
things like that so i said you know
people want to meet hey i'm recently
moved to florida a couple years ago
they're like you want to meet at 5 30 6
o'clock i'm like no
i don't want to i don't want to set an
alarm i did that for college i did that
for my workouts i don't want to do that
but some of that thing i have a sweet
tooth so i love having sweet tooth and
and uh you know now i don't you know
when i was my birthday i remember when i
was at mammoth lakes where i used to
train in california at altitude
my kids and wifey used to have a fruit
cake for me you know i cannot have sugar
sugar because i was in the middle of the
season getting ready for so now i just
say i see dessert i'll have it maybe
twice or three times a day you know
i don't hold back